[Applaudissements]
baïla doha plus grand plaisir de roissy
les cousins voilà sous la peau de
musique oui alors je vais vous dire je
vais je vais citer une chanteuse mais un
peu de musique dans mon coeur mais un
peu de musique dans ma vie ouais qui
chantait ça alors michèle torr nicole 3
1 elle est ou non pas du tout mais un
peu de musique dans mon coeur ou skies a
ouais je crois que ces couches denses et
igor et douchka bello la suite de notre
groupe avec mathieu on reprend tous les
généraux et les versions rice et les 1 2
3 chanas et party méchoui la boucherie
corps présente le groupe 1 de 3h canard
reprend tout est générique télé préférée
avec leur tube qui veut gagner des
millions
mais
[Musique]
penny chiffres tu aimes les lettres des
couleurs version des chiffres et des
lettres
leïla leïla
mais là
[Musique]
un deux ou trois choix n'a c'est aussi
tu es séries préférées comme starsky
hutch
[Musique]
la veille le policier clic les biens qui
sait bien qu'ils quittent sur les
méchants à la paix marie leila et en
bonus track la version rails de carglass
1 on n'a qu'à me missiles vu l'impact
ah oui mais pas plus grands qui dit
dirhams ça passe
lalala artistes ont des moustaches
[Applaudissements]